that also felt really right for some
reason like I miss it sometimes that
feels wrong but I look like this it does
kind of like I miss the hair I miss the
mustache I miss the Vans you know it it
worked for you yeah it really did I kind
of missed myself as well
hi I'm Dan Ratcliffe and I'm Evan Rachel
Wood and this is how I became Weird Al
and how I became Madonna
I first became a fan of Weird Al
properly probably about 10 years ago
when my girlfriend and I started dating
and she introduced me to like I knew a
few of his songs before that but truly
then like my education began on every
road trip or Christmas or whatever it
was we would listen to a lot of it and
yeah gradually I became very very well
acquainted with it to the point where I
was a you know a fan all on my own by
the time that I got the script for this
movie I believe the Immaculate
Collection was one of the first
tapes that I became obsessed with I have
a very early memories of being about
four years old in a tutu with like a
magic wand and bunny ears in my living
room just putting Material Girl on
repeat and just dancing and singing I
even
um would stay home sick from school
sometimes to lip sync
Madonna in the living room I got caught
once so I got an email one day sort of
out of the blue I wasn't really planning
on doing any other projects that year
and then it just said you've been
offered the role of Madonna I
immediately started laughing and then
read the synopsis and realized it was a
weird Al biopic it was a parody Dan was
playing Weird Al you know it was like
the Funny or Die guys and I just thought
oh my God I you know what I'm off my
sabbatical I have to do this and so I
just jumped in we are all grateful yeah
and I uh I similarly I got an email
about the the project for the first time
and read the log line of just like it's
a weird Al biopic and you would be
playing Weird Al and my immediate
reaction was like oh that's you know I I
incredibly cool maybe but there are
definitely people that are closer to him
physically and and you know that I would
have maybe thought of first then I
started reading the script and I
realized that ah right that doesn't
matter yeah accuracy is not what we're
doing here so yeah as of that point it
was just it was it was just such a well
written script as well like it's yes
it's a very funny premise and context
but actually like the way it's executed
and the Precision and thoroughness with
which it gets at the musical biopic
genre is uh it came through in the
script and and and it was obviously
going to be insanely fun to make like
you know when it by the time you get to
the end and I'm like machine gunning
down a room full of you know cocaine in
uh
I'm like this is insane this will be
great fun yeah all I want to say is be
as weird as you want to be
in terms of actually getting into like
character I think there's the aspect of
our that is uh in the movie that is true
to life which is he's the sort of sweet
earnestness that he begins the film with
and so that was obviously something like
you could sort of observe in him and
channel and that was good but I after a
certain point the version of Alan the
movie become so different from the real
human being that it wasn't so much you
know Gathering inspiration from the real
man as much as you know maybe the tenor
of some of the songs and obviously part
of The Madness of UHF we watched UHF
Desperately Seeking Susan watched so
many of her interviews from the early
80s when she was just sort of like
coming on the scene watched The Weird Al
parody interview that he did with her
that he edited together himself
definitely gave that one a gander
constantly on set we were listening to
Madonna and Weird Al music all the time
and then before it takes I would sort of
have an interview or something of hers
that I would listen to or listen to my
trailer just so I had her voice in my
head before we started shooting I really
wanted to get the voice down she has
such a specific way of speaking and so I
definitely I was like if I can get this
down if I can get the mannerisms down if
the audience is coming with me at the
beginning of the film
then they'll go with me where we're
going later on which is like completely
insane and not Madonna Madonna in
another dimension where she's a drug
lord
um and so yeah there were things I
wanted to get right even when you know
I'm just sitting there in a scene you
know you can't just sit how you normally
would you have to sit like Madonna would
you know there's things that you have to
bring to every little moment
um because it counts uh but it's much
less pressure when you know that you can
sort of go off the rails a little bit
and you know it's not totally rooted in
truth the majority but yeah oh yeah yeah
similarly there's the the elements of
Alba I sort of mentioned before that
like sweetness and that kindness and
that's very present I think at the
beginning of the movie but I do think
there's also uh like the secrets where
our successes that that sweetness and
that kindness sits alongside uh kind of
uh like a Mania and a kind of feral
quality that is there in his like live
performances and some of like the the
UHF moments and stuff so I feel like
kept trying to capture like those two
things uh those are the parts of his
character that I guess I really honed in
on and then when it comes to the insane
part of the film you just yeah you just
turn up the uh feral to the 11 and yeah
that was that was basically but yeah it
is it's also as Evan says like it's a
it's a lot of permission to
give a lot of License to go crazy and be
very far from the actual Reality by the
end of the film because it's also nuts
my whole life all I wanted I'm afraid we
found your son had a polka party
[Music]
[Applause]
just to make up new words to a song that
already exists
oh
well you should do that then
the crossing things were amazing and it
was like okay cool yeah this is coming
together you know it was it was nice to
see it honestly seeing the wig glasses
costume and accordion together for the
first time was the memory you're like oh
yeah okay this can this can work this um
yeah this is gonna it's gonna look
alright it felt so right
I miss it sometimes it feels wrong that
I look like this it does kind of like I
miss the hair I miss the mustache I'm a
savance you know it it worked for you
yeah it really did I kind of missed the
mustache as well but um it was you
really do feel like Madonna
when you walk into a trailer that says
Madonna on it you're putting on all the
bracelets and the crucifix you've got
the hair and the makeup going on but it
really feels complete once the beauty
mark was put on it was just like boom
now now we're here now she has arrived
and people treat you like Madonna when
you look like Madonna I've noticed like
when I would come to set it would be
Madonna's on her way Madonna's just
landed Madonna needs a green tea and
then
um you know I would see people get
visibly flustered when they saw me
because it's just like
Instinct almost like
can't help it I when Evan just walked on
me and the whole set we just went uh oh
holy like that's gonna be awesome like
that was it was uh it was a very like
you felt a ripple around the proof of
being like oh wow like yeah no it was
there we're really doing it's gonna work
yeah she's just awesome like she's
incredible like incredibly talented like
the performance was obviously like off
the sharp like there was the Madonna was
like off the charts could like
immediately our first day was like all
the crazy violent make out scenes and
you know we were meeting doing that and
also the first one was us like Rolling
Along down a hallway and knocking a
painting down we would like figuring out
how to both roll and for the painting to
knock and you were like oh well when we
go around the corner I can hit it with
my hand and like it just like there's
just like a technical awareness and a
problem solving a thing which like not
everyone has which I was like oh cool we
didn't eat that as well we've got 18
days thank God she's like this
it's true oh my god well and same you
know like there was a an immediate sort
of understanding whenever you're working
with another person that grew up in the
industry and was a child star and you
know it's like oh you grew up in the
circus as well so like there's there are
things that you get that not everybody
does and you know as you mentioned
there's like a proficiency on set
because of that but what really
impressed me like I was always a fan of
Daniel's work but really you know
sometimes you you work with people and
not then you're like a super fan because
you see their process and what kind of
an actor they are and I was impressed by
just how fully committed he was at all
times he was in every scene there was 18
days it's a high energy performance and
like I never saw you get tired or like
not give as much energy than you did the
first time and I thought that was
incredibly impressive for something like
this to like maintain that level the
whole time I was wondering if you were
going to do a parody of my song like
virgin I'm curious is that song
autobiographical yes
but the fact that I've had a lot of sex
[Laughter]
I don't know we had one dinner and that
was nice yeah like um I don't know I
mean I think it was just sort of
just to make it as weird as possible
honestly like that's not even a stock
answer like it was truly just just like
how ridiculous can we can we make this
how insane can we make Madonna Like how
far can we push this we had this dinner
the night before we started with our
director and then the the next day we
were doing the the crazy crashing around
the house scene so it was like uh yeah
that was either gonna be chemistry or
that wasn't and so we just we decided to
start yeah we had no choice yeah
but the what was really funny was going
and watching playback and watching us
make out and being like wow that's what
it would look like if Madonna and Weird
Al were making out that's it like we're
watching like you could kind of remove
yourself from it in a weird way so I
just love that we were finally getting
to tell their love story so I'm just
gonna throw this out there Weird Al
Yankovic I love it working with rain was
funny I mean like I don't get work with
comedians that often and so that was a
real treat for me and then we had to
like pass our gum back and forth in the
scene and rain kept making jokes
that that was slightly if we weren't
making out throughout the whole scene I
probably would have been laughing the
whole time just because like I can't I'm
no match for somebody like him yeah I
mean I was remembering earlier the one
of the things that kept making me laugh
was actually in the pool party scene
which was just I'll be doing like a
scene with rain or a scene with you know
one of the guys in the band and then I
would just see out of the corner of my
eye you almost to Comey as PeeWee Herman
just sort of walking over in a Peewee
walk and it was just like I truly yeah
very the most distracting thing on the
film Jack Black was amazing as well like
he because everybody on this like you
know we had
it was a fast suit but we were on it the
whole time and we knew it was a fast
shoot whereas like Jack Black was having
to come in for one scene and do a really
big scene and a bit important
performance with like just from a
standing start and he was yeah just
amazing
[Music]
dude I've got chills certainly no one
was expecting me to be able to actually
play anything in the film
um but I think it was just a sort of
best efforts thing where you're like
well I'm playing Weird Al what would I
be doing with my life if I didn't even
just like try for a bit I really enjoyed
learning what I learned it was also it
was it did end up being incredibly
useful for filming and I like to think
that Eric our director didn't have to
shoot around it as much as he would have
had I done no lessons but yeah it's a
fiendishly hard instrument and Al he's a
lovely teacher but I think Alice
forgotten how bad it's possible for
another person to be at the accordion
because he's great
um so like he's playing stuff pretty
fast and I'm like going like okay you're
gonna need to just slow those hands down
because I cannot see what you're doing
um but yeah it was it was uh I can take
that to my grade that I've had according
lessons with Weird Al that's pretty cool
it's like getting a guitar lesson from
Jimi Hendrix yeah yeah
put it in
when Weird Al would talk to me after
scenes about those scenes and the
performance he seemed to be enjoying it
he certainly wasn't giving any like
performance notes but he would often
come in at the end of a scene and just
you know say great job and like how much
he enjoyed something or and you know
when he is saying that and you are
playing him it uh you do go okay you
know I'm still nervous about all this
but I'm relaxing a little bit if you're
having a good time
um so yeah it was very reassuring yes it
was like a safety net and anytime you
were making a laugh
it just
put the wind in your sails it was great
I would see him just sort of pop up out
of the corner of my eye you know on set
you would just kind of see him you know
behind the scenes um but he sort of kept
his distance until you know the end of
the day and then he came up to me and
like gave me a hug and was like oh my
God
your voice your everything what you're
doing just thank you it's so good and
that was like okay good good we're there
we're there we got this Al likes it what
can I say I'm full of surprises oh
what will Madonna think about this film
um that has has yet to be seen but I
think she'll have a good sense of humor
I believe that one of the things that is
true in the film is that she did like
seek out Al took parody one of her songs
and so she must be a fan I've met her
before seemed to be very friendly I hope
that continues after this film is out
but I think she'll like it I think it
should make her laugh I hope oh Al you
can't smoke in here
[Music]
I totally deserve that you know I
thought it would be more divisive
honestly so far like I I thought some
people would be like this is too crazy
so just the fact that it seems to be
finding its audience and the fact that
our fans do seem to really be into it
and see if what it is which is like a
massive crazy celebration of him is yeah
that's lovely yeah it's it's so fun I
mean hearing the audience reaction just
seeing it grow you know we we had a lot
of fun making it but the fact that yeah
it is sort of like taking taking the
World by storm right now is weirdly
fitting like I think people need it and
and want it and like it's such a good
laugh it's so nostalgic there's all
these characters that we know and love
but you're seeing them and just
completely insane ways and so it's like
what's not to like I do think it doesn't
be really happy for all I do think it
has it has prompted just like a sort of
moment of cultural appreciation of Al
and everything he's done which is like
I'm I'm awful lot absolutely
[Music]